Ben Davies tells me that the Padre Pio
movie that had been teased some months
ago with Shia LaBeouf who apparently
converted to Catholicism during the
process of portraying this character
because of the traditional Latin as well
apparently the movie got distribution
the trailer is out I've not seen it yet
we'll take a look at that in the member
block so
I'm gonna I'm Gonna Let You in behind
the scenes here folks
I have a prompter that I occasionally
use I don't use it very much maybe I'll
you know a little intro to the show or
something an advertisement here or there
I'll look at the prompter but most of
the time the prompt is just blank until
Mr Davies writes it he says hey we don't
have the trailer and I get in my ear Mr
Davies tells me uh Michael
the witches are hexing our trailer it's
not it's not popping up but I can't help
but notice anyway we'll get the trailer
maybe we won't we could always do it
tomorrow or something I can't help but
notice though
that it's when we do these
little more religious little more
spiritual segments
all of a sudden sometimes the tech
glitches when I was sitting with Father
Dan rehill
who I saw yesterday and is the Exorcist
that I sat down with we had a two-hour
interview it's available on YouTube we
sit down and we should have been able to
get at least 25 minutes straight without
having to stop for any audio issues and
maybe we could have gotten much more
than that we sit down we start talking
and you don't really see this in the cut
of the interview
about every seven minutes we had to stop
because there was an audio issue
this happens once twice three times
they're stopping okay sorry we got to
stop we got Michael reset whatever and I
said hey guys what's going on they said
we don't really know
and I look over at father rehill and he
says Ah Story of My Life this sort of
thing happens all the time and I
realized I said oh
oh right I'm talking to an exorcist
right now we're speaking about spiritual
reality people might see this and
recognize spiritual reality and they
might even they might come back to the
church they might
oh it's just the devil
and so I turned to our producers I said
hey guys just roll just keep rolling I
don't I don't care if there's an audio
issue we'll figure it out just don't
stop the roll
never happened again
after that moment that some of these
things happen okay now looks like
all of a sudden we've got the trailer
let's play it
I know you shed tears
I know you continued to shed tears every
day because of man's in gratitude
you choose Souls
and despite my unworthiness you've
chosen me
[Music]
the primary source of all human
oppression and exploitation is
individual property what is he talking
about he's talking about
how we can get control of Our Lives
I know you will not refuse let me
courage I know you will provide
take advantage of your suffering
[Music]
put our flag in good hands and we win
did you ever come back here I stood you
it feels like a sin to question these
things it feels like a center
angry with the Lord
there is no greater love than this to
give one's life for one's friends
knowing about this at the field at the
spiritual sanctity
say Christ is Lord say Christ is Lord
fill out
repair the fire
I'm interested I don't know how it is
I'm sometimes a little skeptical of
religious movies especially we're
talking about really really important
men like Saint Padre Pio
so we'll see how it's handled but I'm
interested and apparently coincidentally
today is Padre pio's birthday according
to
the Catholic producer Danny so
I'm interested Padre Pio
he's one if you don't know much about
him Google him pretty interesting guy a
pretty important figure in the 20th
century and they've all right they've
convinced me enough that I want to see
that movie comes out apparently June 2nd
all right that's our show I'm Michael
knows this the Michael Knowles show see
you tomorrow boy what a clip if you want
more of that if you want long interviews
if you want the yes or no game if you
want The Daily Show you got to check out
the Michael Knowles YouTube channel and
ring that Bell And subscribe we'll see
you next time